hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 el 18 de octubre se cumplió un
año del histórico estallido social que
sacudió a chile y que continúa
movilizando lo hablamos del movimiento
que comenzó con un rechazo al aumento
del precio de los pasajes del metro y
que sumó reclamos por mejores salarios
educación de calidad pensiones dignas
entre muchos otros pero que tenían en
común la exigencia de una reforma
estructural en el sistema político
social y económico del país
la protesta tomó también el reclamo de
una nueva constitución y por eso el
próximo 25 de octubre los chilenos
asistirán a un plebiscito para elegir si
desean una nueva carta magna que
reemplacen a la que tienen heredada de
la dictadura de augusto pinochet y para
dialogar sobre estos temas nos acompaña
karol cariola ella es diputada de chile
por el partido comunista y también fue
además una de las integrantes del masivo
movimiento de estudiantes chilenos en
reclamo de educación de calidad y
gratuita que junto a otros compañeros y
compañeras llegaron al congreso de su
país karol cariola muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en la entrevista de
france 24
hola santiago qué gusto de saludarte y
saludar a todos ya todas quienes nos
están viendo hoy gracias a vos caron
bueno a un año de lester haya sido
social no que sacudió a chile miras
hacia atrás hacia aquel momento lo
comparas con el actual que pensás cómo
evaluás las respuestas a sus reclamos
cuál es su reflexión carol
bueno sin lugar a dudas parece que fue
ayer nos el primer 18 de octubre que
para nosotros ha sido muy importante
santiago
digo para nosotros los chilenos y la
chilena tú sabes que nuestro país hace
muchos años que viene viviendo una
situación muy compleja del desarrollo
del neoliberalismo que dejó implementado
la dictadura militar consolidado a
través de una institucionalidad que se
reposa en la actual constitución que fue
también heredada de la dictadura militar
y que nadie entiende en el mundo porque
después de 30 años de haber recuperado
la democracia todavía mantenemos la
constitución de la dictadura militar
entonces fueron muchas las razones por
las cuales el movimiento social los
estudiantes los estudiantes secundarios
que fueron quienes saltaron el
torniquete de los movimientos
estudiantiles ya lo decía el movimiento
los trabajadores y trabajador el
movimiento feminista
fueron fuimos tan relevantes también y
detonando de alguna manera esta lucha
progresiva de acumulación de fuerza que
hoy día de alguna manera nos tiene a un
año de un proceso de movilización de los
más importantes que hemos vivido en
chile que además ha venido santiago un
proceso constituyente la posibilidad de
dejar atrás esa herencia y la dictadura
militar y cambiar la constitución con la
voluntad popular así que bueno son
muchos los buenos recuerdos creo que el
país no sé no deja de tener este ímpetu
no esta fuerza de lucha se sigue viendo
en las calles la necesidad de seguir
manifestándose a raíz de que bueno si
bien hemos iniciado un cambio importante
a través del proceso constituyente
lamentablemente muchas cosas que todavía
se mantienen igual como por ejemplo la
represión policial claro ahora voy a
preguntarte más adelante sobre este
plebiscito tan importante no hay clave
que van a vivir los chilenos pero antes
quería hablar de las manifestaciones de
2019 que dejaron decenas de muertos
miles de personas detenidas incluso
denuncias por abusos sexuales por
violaciones a los derechos
por parte de organismos internacionales
también y esto sucedió también en las
nuevas manifestaciones de ahora de 2020
salieron a la luz de imágenes de un
policía arrojando a un joven al mapocho
no a un río que casi no tiene caudal de
agua en la capital chilena caron a qué
obedece crees voz este accionar de las
fuerzas policiales de chile
mira ha sentido lamentablemente yo creo
que durante muchos años en nuestro país
el valor de la democracia se vio
trastocado el producto de una lógica que
quedó instaurada por la dictadura
militar una policía extremadamente
violenta con muy poco control civil
quiero decir con esto que finalmente la
policía responde a una lógica
militarizada
probablemente las más brutales de
américa latina en relación a las formas
que utiliza para reprimir a su propio
pueblo y eso es algo que nos ha llevado
a cuestionarnos profundamente cuál es el
rol que cumple la policía en este caso
carabineros de chile en nuestro país si
el rol de proteger a la ciudadanía de
entregarle seguridad o el rol de
maltratar violentar e incluso llegar a
violar los derechos humanos tan
fundamentales hace algunos días salió un
nuevo informe de amnistía internacional
que da cuenta de que hay efectivos
policiales incluidos en ellos los altos
mandos de cara de dinero que deben tener
sanciones penales eso es lo que
recomienda amnistía internacional lo
mismo otros informes human right watch
salió un informe de la alta comisionada
de derechos humanos de la onu y así
varios otros informes internacionales
dieron cuenta de que esta policía no
sólo no estaba a la altura sino que
efectivamente ha violado de manera
generalizada e incluso sistemática
levemente los derechos humanos en
nuestro país y lo que tú comentabas de
anthony un joven dice
años que fue arrojado por un policía al
río mapocho nos trajo los peores
recuerdos de la dictadura militar en
chile muchos de los asesinados muchos de
los ejecutados políticos por la
dictadura fueron tirados al río mapocho
y ver como el cuerpo un joven quiera
boca abajo sangrando sin recibir ayuda
sino que muy por el contrario se
fortaleció la represión en ese momento
de los manifestantes que estaban
alrededor del río mapocho la verdad es
que y que fue rescatado finalmente por
personas por manifestantes que estaban
en el lugar y no por la policía uno dice
que claramente esta policía no nos
protege es una policía que nos genera
inseguridad que nos reprime y que
lamentablemente hoy está poniendo y
mostrando a la luz pública la peor de
sus facetas la faceta más
antidemocrática por eso también es que
se está gestando y ya se presentó una
acusación constitucional al ministro del
interior
al ministro pérez cierto a propósito
precisamente de esta situación ya que él
es el responsable político del actuar de
carabineros de chile cal del próximo 25
de octubre habrá finalmente un
plebiscito nacional en el que los
ciudadanos van a elegir si quieren o no
una nueva constitución tienes esperanza
en esta oportunidad para cambiar la
carta magna chilena
mucha esperanza santiago yo realmente
creo que el pueblo de chile ha hecho un
esfuerzo gigante heroico
con muchos dolores también yo te quiero
decir si bien nos sentimos muy
orgullosos de la lucha popular del
esfuerzo de las masivas movilizaciones
de de situaciones inéditas que vivimos
también es importante decir que no nos
olvidamos y que vamos a exigir todas las
acciones de justicia de no impunidad en
función de aquellos compatriotas que
perdieron la vida en estas
movilizaciones que perdieron sus ojos en
estas movilizaciones aquellos que fueron
torturados porque hubo situaciones de
ese tipo que vivieron el maltrato del
estado sólo por querer un país mejor
sólo por querer una vida más digna sólo
por querer un poquito más de igualdad y
por eso es que yo me siento esperanzada
porque creo que este proceso se abrió
con mucho esfuerzo el pueblo chileno con
mucha resistencia y si hoy tenemos un
proceso constituyente que se encamina un
plebiscito nacional que histórico a los
chilenos y a las chilenas jamás nos han
preguntado si queremos o no tener una
nueva constitución la última
constitución que se hizo en chile la
impuso una dictadura entre cuatro
paredes a sangre y fuego hoy tenemos la
oportunidad histórica
abrir un proceso constituyente de
iniciar un proceso constituyente que se
inicia en las calles que se consolida
además creo yo con este plebiscito que
tenemos el 25 de octubre y que de alguna
manera también nos va a permitir
reflejar que el pueblo chileno durante
muchos años ha venido anhelando tener
una nueva carta fundamental un nuevo un
nuevo trato entre los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas chile es un país de los más
desiguales de américa latina y del mundo
la distribución de la riqueza de gigante
el 0.1 por ciento
la diferencia gigante el 0,1 por ciento
de los chilenos y chilenas concentran el
34 por ciento de la riqueza entonces son
muchas las desigualdades mientras que la
gran mayoría de los chilenos durante la
pandemia que además agudizó las
contradicciones de este modelo económico
finalmente se han tenido que alimentar
en ollas comunes entonces cambiar la
constitución obvio que nos genera gran
expectativa y esperanza para pensar en
una democracia soberana donde el pueblo
tenga mayor participación y decisión
claro si se llega a probar no voy a
tener una nueva constitución en chile se
abre la puerta para muchísimas
modificaciones del sistema cuáles son
las más urgentes
en la que podrían ser históricas digamos
por decirlo de alguna manera
bueno primero ya es histórico tener el
plebiscito que este que la convención
constitucional que es la opción por la
cual la gran mayoría de los chilenos y
chilenas vamos que para poder elegir a
todos los representantes va a ser
paritaria pero además de eso
efectivamente en términos de contenido
yo creo que al menos del debate que
hemos venido dando santiago tiene que
ver con cambiar el rol del estado tener
un estado garante de derecho pasar de
esta lógica de estado subsidiario que
mira desde afuera que no garantiza
derechos fundamentales a un estado
garante a un estado con un que
establezca y que reconozca una
democracia soberana participativa donde
las chilenas y los chilenos tengamos
posibilidades de tomar decisiones
respecto de lo que ocurre en nuestro
país el implementar iniciativas
populares como la iniciativa popular de
ley el garantizar derechos como la salud
la educación la vivienda que son
derechos que lamentablemente en nuestro
para el sistema de cambiar el sistema de
pensiones que son derechos que
lamentablemente en chile se privatizaron
durante muchos años y que hasta ahora lo
que ha ocurrido es que con las pensiones
se negocia con la salud se negocia con
la educa
se negocia y los derechos fundamentales
de los ciudadanos y ciudadana han
quedado completamente de lado raíz de
este estado subsidiario que está más
bien al servicio del mercado entonces
esa correlación de fuerza hoy debe
cambiar y el proceso constituyente y la
nueva constitución se debe configurar a
partir de esa premisa de una
constitución que garantice derecho que
establezca un estado democrático pero
con una democracia real una democracia
con soberanía popular una democracia con
participación ciudadana y que de alguna
manera también nos permita consolidar
cambios estructurales en el modelo
económico yo creo que chile se merece y
necesita un nuevo modelo de desarrollo
nuestra activista mucho más como una
mejor convivencia con respecto al
sistema o sea al medio ambiente hoy día
nosotros tenemos un sistema
tremendamente depredador del medio
ambiente que nos está generando gran
pero gran daño a nuestra población claro
nos quedan menos de un minuto pero no
quiero dejar de preguntarte cómo has
recibido la respuesta del presidente
sebastián piñera que respaldo a las
fuerzas después de estas últimas
manifestaciones lo citó dijo que junto
con lamentar lo ocurrido quería
su profundo respaldo a la institución de
carabineros de chile
bueno sabemos y al menos santiago en
nuestro en chile- sabemos quién es el
principal responsable de la represión
quién es el principal responsable de los
casos de violaciones a los derechos
humanos quién es el principal
responsable de la división entre los
chileno al presidente piñera le declaró
la guerra al pueblo de chile días de
iniciado el estallido social esto la
revuelta en nuestro país y creo que el
reflejo de lo que él dice ahora es más
de lo que ya conocíamos no por eso en
algún momento hubo diputado dentro de
los que me incluyo que queríamos llevar
adelante una acusación constitucional
contra el presidente de la república que
lamentablemente no prosperó por algunos
votos desde la oposición que prefirieron
cuadrarse con el gobierno en vez de
hacer justicia y terminar con una
impunidad que es inaceptable que es
vergonzosa y que lamentablemente este
presidente que no cree en la democracia
sigue reafirmando karol cariola
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer dialogar contigo
muchas gracias a ti santiago que estés
muy bien saludos a todos ya todas muchas
gracias ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]